kansas state police are investigating a
violent arrest caught on video we should
warn you this footage is extremely
graphic and disturbing it appears to
show a man being violently attacked by
officers as he is pinned to the ground
nikki batis is here with more on what
happened nikki good morning
vlad good morning this happened sunday
in crawford county arkansas near the
oklahoma border one officer is on leave
and two deputies have been suspended
pending the state police investigation
as the authorities share their version
of what happened
disturbing cell phone video appears to
show two crawford county deputies and
one mulberry police officer pinning
randall warchester to the ground and
repeatedly punching him in the head and
kneeing him in the legs
then one officer lifts worchester's head
up and smashes it into the ground
the video does not show what happened
before the arrest the crawford county
sheriff told our cbs affiliate kfsm it
started around 11 miles away in alma
arkansas he said alma police responded
to a call about a man making terroristic
threats against a gas station employee
the man allegedly spit on the employee
and threatened to cut off their face he
then biked to mulberry where the officer
and deputies in the video met with him
the sheriff said the conversation
started calmly but escalated when
warchester allegedly pushed one of the
deputies to the ground and punched him
in the back of the head it is unclear if
worchester was armed the banging of the
head against the ground
no
that is not appropriate former police
officer keith taylor is an adjunct
assistant professor at the john jay
college of criminal justice he says he
sees little justification for the
officer's actions the punching in the
face it was unrelenting
i can understand if you're in a battle
with the person but you've got one
person laying on and the other person
kicking the heck out of his legs or
lower body those are serious
pieces of force
state police say worchester was taken to
a local hospital for treatment and then
later jailed he faces numerous charges
including terroristic threatening
resisting arrest second degree assault
and second degree battery and a big
question i have is whether or not there
was any body camera video we just don't
know yet well certainly once they saw
that people were shooting on cell phone
cameras you see them pointing mm-hmm
it's hard to watch we're all wincing
yeah and the question is not whether he
was a bad dude or not the question is
whether that was objection objectively
reasonable that's the standard thank you
thank you very much we'll keep following
it